you might know Keurig as the single
serve coffee maker pop in a pod and
voila one cup of coffee but curious got
a new machine and it's got some fancy
new features like a color touch display
a night light and it's bigger Keurig 2.0
can Brew one to four cups at a time the
company says this was something that
their customers really wanted the second
difference a new type of K-Cup pod this
is important because competitors started
making generics of the old pod the
company makes more than 70 of its
revenue from these pods now the question
we have is Keurig 2.0 any better than
your average home coffee maker we
brought in a Mr Coffee to compare
Keurig 2.0 was the clear winner only two
and a half minutes for the Keurig more
than seven minutes for Mr Coffee
as for taste
we use Green Mountain French Rose coffee
in both Brewers and asked our colleagues
to pick their favorite cup brown cup
brown Cup wins I like brown better the
other one's brown brown it is the winner
this one's better the majority thought
Keurig 2.0 tasted better
Keurig 2.0 cost anywhere from 150 to 200
Mr Coffee 25 bucks so which one's better
I guess it depends how much you're
willing to pay and how big a rush you're
in